[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight i'm jesse waters and for
tucker the left's still in a complete
meltdown over glenn young's win in
virginia they're accusing anybody who
voted for him of being a tiki torch
carrying white supremacist more on that
in a minute but first donald trump
officially became the republican nominee
for president in mid-july of 2016. just
days later a russian national living in
this country made a claim that would
upend donald trump's candidacy and
eventually his presidency it's a claim
that changed the course of u.s politics
for the next four years
the russian national a man named igor
denchenko
said he had just received a phone call
proving that donald trump's campaign was
conspiring with the russian government
the phone call supposedly came from u.s
citizen who was serving as president of
the russian american chamber of commerce
that alleged phone call became the
central piece of evidence in the steele
dossier written by british ex-spy
christopher steele that dossier in turn
was a key piece of evidence in the fbi's
warrant applications to spy on the trump
campaign
the government leaked information on the
supposedly secret warrant applications
to the media and the russian collusion
narrative began in january buzzfeed
published the steele dossier online
buzzfeed's editor justified publishing
the document by saying the fbi was
supposedly taking it seriously
this document that is being fought over
that and that by the way everybody
except the public in a certain sense has
seen we've seen you know and we don't
have any special powers
does the audience say you know we can we
can see this too and we can deal with
the fact that it is clearly labeled as
unverified that it's clearly labeled
that some things in it aren't true which
is what we did i i kind of get it i mean
so what you're saying is because famous
people are gossiping about it and
because other famous people the
president of the united
a document that by the way is a public
document subject to the freedom of
information law well actually in some
senses gossip because it's unverified
and the difference between what you did
what judge did was what judge reported
turned out to be true whereas it looks
like what you reported is not true
there were obvious red flags with the
dossier from the very beginning for one
thing christopher steele was working for
an opposition research firm called
fusion gps which was funded by the
hillary clinton campaign
and the dossier made several obviously
false claims for example it stated that
the trump campaign was working with
hackers in the russian consulate in
miami
but there is no russian consulate in
miami
but for partisan reasons media
personalities overlooked all that they
insisted the dossier was reliable
the allegations in this christopher
steele dossier and you went through the
timeline very well a few moments ago are
stunning they're actually substantial
portions of what was in the steele
dossier which was a raw intelligence
document that have indeed checked out
based on our own reporting and word from
numerous official sources the dossier in
fact is far from bogus i think we're
going to actually have to stop calling
it the infamous dossier increasingly
it's the accurate dossier today thanks
to an indictment from u.s attorney john
durham we learned the truth it turns out
that there was no late july 26 phone
call to igor d'anchenko about russian
collusion
igor denchanko wasn't speaking to the
head of the russian-american chamber of
commerce about donald trump or about
anything at all
instead according to today's indictment
the source of much of denchenko's
information was a democratic party
operative and a former hillary clinton
advisor
we can identify that clinton adviser
tonight his name is charles dolan
in other words hillary clinton's team
wasn't just funding the steele dossier
they were effectively writing it too
dolan by the way has extensive
connections to russia closer connections
did anybody on donald trump's team had
from 2006 to 2014 for example dolan did
pr work on behalf of the russian
government and a russian energy company
according to durham's indictment in
august 2016 dancho told dolan that he
was working on quote a project against
trump unquote
dolan responded by saying he had just
received dirt on paul manafort who was
donald trump's campaign manager at the
time from a quote gop friend
it was all a lie
according to today's indictment quote
dolan later acknowledged to the fbi that
he never met with a gop friend in
relation to this information that he
passed to denchanko but rather
fabricated the fact of the meeting and
his communications with dengca
throughout 2016 dolan and other
political operatives continued to feed
denchenko more lies about the trump
campaign
the indictment states for example that
one of denchenko sources believed the
ex-clinton aide would quote take me to
the state department if hillary wins
denchenko himself also lied about
traveling to the moscow hotel in the
summer of 2016. a trip where he
supposedly gathered information about
the infamous p tape
denchenko lied about all of this to the
fbi he never told them he was working
for a former hillary clinton aide
so the big question is how did
denchenko's lies and all of his bogus
conversations with these sources get
into the steele dossier who connected
thenchenko to christopher steele
well
the indictment says that a member of the
national security council named fiona
hill
first introduced danchanko to steele
if that name sounds familiar it's
because fiona hill was one of the
democratic party's witnesses against
donald trump in his first impeachment
trial
now she's popped up again as one of the
key figures behind the steele dossier
that's either an incredible coincidence
or a sign that our national security
establishment's even more corrupt than
we thought it was
but it gets worse
the fbi it turns out knew for years that
d'anchenko's sourcing was garbage
they included his claims in search
warrant applications against the trump
campaign regardless
declassified footnotes from a doj
inspector general report revealed that
the fbi suspected chris steele's dossier
was a part of an elaborate russian
disinformation campaign
one of the footnotes said the bureau
quote did not have high confidence in
the subset of steel's reporting and
assess that the reference subset was
part of a russian disinformation
campaign to denigrate u.s foreign
relations
that subset referred to the activities
of former trump lawyer michael cohen
who steals dossier claimed to travel to
prague to meet with russian agents
special counsel robert mueller couldn't
find anything to support that claim and
cohen denied it it was totally made up
durham's indictment today makes it even
more clear that the fbi knew the dossier
was a scam
according to today's indictment june
2017
fbi agents interviewed denchenko in
virginia agents asked danchanko about
his contacts with the clinton aide
charles dolan d'anchenko lied and said
he didn't talk to dolan
the fbi agent documented at the time he
knew it was a lie but nothing happened
the fbi didn't prosecute denchenko
robert mueller didn't even mention any
of this in his report until today until
john durham's indictment no one in the
government did a thing
now denchenko faces five federal charges
including lying to the fbi to hide his
conversations with dolan
and this could just be the beginning
we're learning a lot about the collusion
hoax very quickly weeks ago
john durham indicted dnc lawyer named
michael sussman for lying to the fbi
about a secret channel of communications
between the trump organization and a
russian bank
durham has also secured a guilty plea
from an ex-fbi attorney who lied about
the trump campaign's ties to russia
now we're learning that hillary clinton
allies gave information to a hillary
clinton contractor and laundered it all
of it into the fbi and the department of
justice
more than four years after that
fabricated july 26 phone call
some of these criminals are finally
going to jail
kim strassel is a call